alright welcome video just a spontaneous
decision to make a quick video here of
turn the material chess cube on some the
rapid blitz tournament so it's a three
minute time control so somewhat slower
than the usual here usually we have two
minute or 1 minute let's still need to
press the doubling cube yeah I accepted
yeah 3 minutes so it's it's somewhat
more serious but still you need to win
quickly this also dictate some opening
choices trying to play am somewhat
aggressive yeah of course I have no idea
about the bank oh let's see what happens
was it Queen and take a five between 85
or something yeah to speed up a bit bit
early to to have long things here let me
just eat six at some point Queen 85 I
can't assess Bishop t2 away with this
one yeah what a three minutes and this
is an I don't play this this tournament
soft because it's very much a matter of
luck how many games you you get in it
very much depends some on your
opponent's if they resign early if they
play on Queens down and so on but well
let's see what what happens here i'm
just a pawn down for somewhat shady
compensation got some some central
control at least if you play c5 now I
could
94 yeah I have I have some some play in
the center but of course it's somewhat
shaky position e 7 is also hanging hmm I
go Bishop d6 you might go Queen e6 not
sure this is dangerous but I need to
move the bishop if it goes here he
always needs to check out for those
discoveries so 95 om I'm finding myself
this is Sir this is it convenient didn't
really take that into account yeah we
should see some yeah i'm just a pawn
down you could also play a queen e seven
then maybe half not bt7 what this is
this is a great start here and i'm just
a pawn down for absolutely nothing and
half a crap position great well maybe
I've got some activity that's let's see
what happens here we should g6 now all
this looks this looks just brilliant
yeah this is just just bad maybe maybe
lost even you took me to play quickly
maybe you do some some stupid things but
position wise it's just a wreck c5 is so
completely completely we don't see much
really
yeah but it also looks like he's doing a
good job here before now my night has no
square
yo this was a brilliant start yeah this
is reading the bank of course I don't
know it all so I'm on place 86 now ok
let's try to get in a quick win here
four pawns attacking the alack alack 11
or whatever cannot pronounce this at
least it looks Oh looks aggressive look
somewhat weakening here
but of course I'm not really an expert
here maybe he's trying to go night
before should prevent this yeah try to
fortify the center here
yeah this is so this will be a quick run
a quick win I guess no idea what I'm
doing here you know d5 try to get a
piece on a form yeah looks okay for me
yeah the sort of game is of course no go
to to catch up here yeah of course you
can do that but I didn't think this this
would be good to radium console and
right even if i take here this one is
still hanging and i'm also yeah of
course you can do that but it should
still the tempo yeah the ad for
threatening on b7 so i've got two pieces
now on to pieces now for the rook yeah i
might go 95 me i should just take the
square and prevent this these two pieces
here are nicely protecting each other
and i still have threats coming up
against them against c6 all right
yeah cannot allow membership to be taken
yeah now I can go to c5 and grab c6 next
yeah okay can exchange but this is
really nice setup now these two units
protect each other the bishop protects
g2 so all very nice okay should I
capture now I'll play be 5v5 looks like
a dangerous answer that he's got to also
pawn it's got the a poem and sometimes
how to stop these pods if they're
supported by rook so I just take this
look simpler maybe the other one was
from from a purely technical part of you
better but yeah okay this one was was
protected k plays on again I think the C
porn would have decided anyway so now I
just need to check here on this diagonal
to promote the pawn
yeah yeah this costs points playing on
this kind of positions if he lets the
clock run down low okay we didn't so I'm
still I'm just 0 points after two really
too too too long games so if I want to
get anywhere in the tournament okay this
helped just two points but so trying to
to get a quick win and now it's only
rated 1400 playing gambit style here
yeah maybe takes and I can grab the f7
yeah yeah one the queen of those this
nice little trick here okay
we all need to develop quickly money for
I can just take check here I especially
six flicking h3 may be here okay it just
takes
yeah I'm gonna clean up but place on the
sir of course cost valuable time
oops i was expecting work takes of
course i would have played Bishop h6 if
I wouldn't have pre move this but now
okay this helps a bit
is them made somewhere maybe with a bit
of help yeah this is made king here be
three and push up someone made all right
eight points at least I'm in the top ten
yeah this loss of course leads didn't
help first game oops order to play e5
don't really like the French in this
kind of tournaments so it takes too long
sometimes two to win right exchange
variation are not the most inspiring
choice really helps no it doesn't help
ok the I didn't really select that the
best line tool to get some to get some
imbalance here what's moving at a too
quickly
yeah no white even might have a small
advantage online
I a stupid I wanted to play one year
five of course this is just just better
to to get some group tactics going and
now i need to to play this crap position
that's our most likely taking ages to
get something here
maybe I can irritate am a bit here it's
not knowing doing much really attack
I am not really threatening rupee eight
because it can take unfortunately no I'm
threatening or piayed and you can always
go go in to see one so it's not an
immediate when i get deform yeah
not quite sure what is wrong okay I grab
this yeah I didn't see Quincy one
strangely enough yeah just the Queen up
a 12-course that gets played on thanks
so knock or sub place back in the hunt
ok let's try to flag to fear because I
have no idea what the dragon so to see
it this might end up ugly yeah this is
an online they form a force mostly
played and also castle it's really
amazing young some of 1800 player
playing a rather rail line okay let's
see if he is playing with a book or
something he takes on a for now then you
know yeah great this is this is just
yeah okay he's son having some help or
something I guess seems unrealistic that
he knows all this all this stuff yeah
okay Sunni to play him
okay don't want Matt you form now black
has quite decent compensation for the
exchange it so it's not it's not a
vantage for black or something but let's
play alone right Scott this great night
on c5 now helping to block the position
but of course this is a purely young
defensive set up for public you never
know at least if I'm not doing something
stupid you would never be able to to get
some selectivity here this is a bit
loose about need to get a bit going on
I've got about 26 needed to keep the six
detect okay
yeah this ugly
need to try to set the exchange back
here this night is too strong
I Scott rupee one is this problem I can
just play kingi to wheel
I hope
working h2 may be okay didn't happen
this is of course I'm nothing for white
look so about equal
I
sloths an end game you can always test
people in the end game yeah this is now
some advantage for white not brilliant
but I've I just got the better of here
if he allows f5 now and five this is a
nice space advantage we need to keep all
these pawns protected and so difficult
to see how you should get some activity
going here yeah okay what about just
taking 1d6 now rook takes I could do to
the f6 pawn but I all record also go to
the pawn end game which is takes takes
King c 17d 5qd 7 could be winning I'm
not sure playing the safe route here
this is some just one end game
yeah of course I won't manage the time
this is it stupid just I just invested
far too much time to think about this
pawn endgame yeah yeah of course I have
no chance to do anything in this journey
sixteenth plays yeah this three minutes
game these three minute games just mean
that you don't get so much games played
so you cannot really afford to to lose
stupid coins like the one I I lost in
the first game and and what I would
adjust it you simply need to win six or
seven games and that's it and of course
it's helpful of people just resign their
games and don't drag on with Queens down
and so on but that just played badly so
nothing to complain just need to win
this couple of games
yeah just two pawns for for nothing
try to get the route to you too yeah we
can capture it does it doesn't really
matter check check again and now this
light is gone as well because I can
exchange looks but i try to maybe get a
mate going here will be too hard too
hard to prevent really yeah this is made
next more fun can I do anything against
this look 5 to be too mate ok try
another ok didn't take the blue one
yeah this is so fairly solid for black
it's not turn not much what can do here
of course I can freely develop here but
don't have any any special attack or
something
you can try to get something only five
ya can play G for now crappy five this
looks really lose
not sure I wanted let's just play play
normal Lucia ok I'm not sure that this
is really normal but it don't don't play
G for what I was trying to say when p6
actually have the night season I see six
square so I needs to protect this some
yeah with the piece on or making make a
sacrifice out of it ok I now try to
break this pin here exchange it so it
doesn't exchange ok
we try to activate it this way
okay then I played you for whatever all
right now you for saying this was all a
bit too quickly I can't take it for now
I didn't this is good news yeah this
looks like i'm a nice position again
this night is annoying b7 as always
under pressure and he cannot really play
b6 because of 96 so this is some an
annoying position for black hair the
zone gives me a great night on c4 which
is yeah cannot easily be expelled here
v6 still 96 rock da I can just take yeah
well this should be something I play da
g5 now and grab you form of course can
he will detect g5 so like I just need to
learn to protect g5 first so let's say
night here gh4 and then grab a form yeah
this looks nice get out too much against
this e7 is hanging first so he cannot
grab g5 yup this pin oh I could have
played 36 also where I can play the snow
right
you yeah those nights to a good job here
cannot take rupee eight is checkmate and
everything's hanging both rooks and the
bishop yeah this loses almost all pieces
yeah
yeah check made so I jhump28 place here
close to to the others here yeah just I
just played badly the first first place
here played also eight games just like I
did if you want all late and I
considered this draw and the stupid lost
the first round okay maybe i can i can
get some really outer clue could win yet
but he completely misplayed this King's
gambit but 20 seconds only possible if
he resigns or resigns early or allow
something really drastic okay it's just
a piece for nothing but 10 seconds you
will just let them oh he resigns nice
this is rare okay it does it help much
because first three places get some
cubits and I place for oh ok ok this
wasn't really a game so at the end
fourth place I got nine games in which
is even one more than the first two guys
here but I had this really ugly loss of
the first game which also took close to
six minutes this is even worse than the
loss itself and and the one draw we had
the rook the ad this was simply stupid
time management otherwise ok I might
have had a chance to fight but eight out
of eight is certainly deserved win year
for for the first place first place
player yeah thanks for watching and I'll
up new videos maybe on no question maybe
on Sunday next couple of days of course
yeah see you then why